YUFENG GUO: Not everyone
uses SQL, but if you do,
wouldn't it be nice to be
able to use machine learning
within your SQL environment?
BigQuery ML does just that.
Stay tuned to find out how.
Welcome to AI Adventures, where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo,
and on this episode,
we're going to try
out BigQuery ML, which
enables you to
create and execute
machine learning
models in BigQuery
using standard SQL queries.
Currently, BigQuery
ML, or BQML for short,
supports linear regression,
binary logistic regression,
and multiclass
logistic regression.
Linear regressions
are models which
predict a numerical value, like
an insurance premium or a home
value.
Binary logistic
regressions are models
which predict one
of two classes,
like identifying
whether a machine needs
to be checked for maintenance
work, a yes or a no, or perhaps
more famously, whether an
image is a cat or a dog.
Multiclass logistic
regressions are models which
predict more than two classes--
for example, whether or not
you should buy, hold, or sell
a stock, or if, say,
traffic on the highway
is light, medium,
heavy, or a parking lot.
Let's see what BQML
looks like in practice.
You can access it
via the BigQuery UI
or through the
command line and API.
Today, we'll look at
it on the BigQuery UI,
but the queries we'll use
are identical to if you use
the command line or the API.
I've got some sample data here
from Google Analytics, taken
from a BigQuery public data set.
We did an episode on the
BigQuery public data sets
program a while back, so
be sure to check that out
to learn more about all
the public data sets that
are free for you to use.
Now, let's take a look
at our data set today.
Notice that we're looking
specifically at whether or not
a transaction took place.
That's what we'll be
trying to predict later on.
Now, what will we base
these predictions on?
We have the operating
system of the user's device,
whether it was a mobile device
or not, the country of origin,
and the number of page views
that the user performed.
I have a feeling
that last column,
that's probably going
to be pretty useful.
Notice also that we're pulling
data from this sample data
set from between August
2016 through June of 2017.
OK, let's try building
a model to see
if we can make some predictions
based on these criteria,
on these columns.
We'll add a create
model statement
at the top with the table name,
and give our sample a name--
say, just sample model.
And we'll pass in some options,
including the fact that we're
doing a logistic regression.
So we're just going
to say yes or no, one
of two options, whether or
not a transaction took place.
I'll just put that at the
top of our SELECT statement.
And that's really
the only edit you'll
need to turn your
query into a model.
Now, while that's
running, I want
to point out that the
aliasing on that first column
of transactions, to
call it a label, that
wasn't a coincidence.
BQML looks specifically
for a column named label
so that it can figure out which
column you want to predict on
and which are the columns
you want as inputs.
So if you don't want to
create a column called label,
for some reason, or if you have
a column actually called label
that you don't want
to use this label,
you can set the input
label calls option
in the create model statement.
Say we call that column
transactions instead, right,
and there was no
column called labels.
Then we could do
something like this,
where we pass in the
name transactions
as the column to look
for as our label.
What's really
handy about BQML is
that you don't need to move your
data anywhere to take advantage
of its features, since it's
built right into BigQuery.
This means that it can
serve as a really easy way
to get a first look at any
notable patterns in your data.
Once your model has
started training,
you can check out the training
statistics if you want--
click on the model in
the left-hand panel
and go over to the Model
Stats tab down below.
There, you can see
the train progress
as it works through the data
set and improves the model
performance with each pass.
Now, when the create model
statement finishes running,
it's time to run evaluation
using ML.EVALUATE.
We'll take the original SQL
query that we had for the data
set and wrap it in
ML.EVALUATE, passing
in the newly created
model and then selecting
from that result.
You will get an
output that includes
a number of different
metrics of your model.
Notice that we've
actually queried
dates that are outside of the
range of the training data.
And specifically, it's the month
immediately following the dates
that we use to train on.
We don't want to pass
in the training data
for evaluation,
because that would
be like cheating on a test.
Finally, it's time
to run Predict.
Here, we'll wrap that same
query we used during evaluation
with the ML.PREDICT function,
and pass the model in as well.
This particular
prediction groups
up the countries so we can
see what their predictions are
for each country ranked.
We can also see that for
this particular data set,
most of the transactions
came from the United States,
though it might be
worth diving in deeper
to see how these match
up across mobile devices
and different operating systems.
So that's BigQuery ML in
a nutshell-- a simple way
to do some easy
machine learning right
within your SQL environment.
I'm looking forward to
seeing what models you build.
Thanks for watching this
episode of Cloud AI Adventures.
And if you enjoyed it, be
sure to hit that Like button
and subscribe to get all
the latest updates right
when they come out.
For now, check out BigQuery
ML and start building
your first model today.